with 15 minutes to go until the midterms
a huge swing in momentum for the GOP as
Democrats wetting their pants sorry
Harold
yes we are officially on a red tsunami
watch but it seems like nobody's told
Joe yet instead of hitting the campaign
Trail and talking to voters President
Biden was cooped up inside a butt with a
bunch of DNC staffers I bet it smelled
wonderful Biden giving a rousing pep
talk on how his party has it all in the
bag
we're running against the tide and we're
beating the tide we the Democrats are
the ones that are fiscally responsible
let's get that straight now Republicans
are fiscally Reckless pushing tax cuts
for the very wealthy that aren't paid
for and exploiting a deficit that is
making inflation worse Republicans are
determined to hold the economy hostage
either given to their demands on Social
Security Medicare which millions of
Americans rely on and earned and paid
for
Republicans are going to crash the
economy that is rousing and if Biden's
blame the Republican strategy fails to
catch on there's a Nancy Pelosi method
of changing the subject
it's about getting out the vote
everything else is a conversation
compared to that but in order to do that
you have to have inspiration you can't
run on empty and the fact is is that
when I hear people talk about inflation
as I heard him there we have to change
that subject the fight is not about
inflation it's about the cost of living
are they connected yes the media going
one step further to help Democrats spin
the bad news by saying inflation is all
in your head
joining me now to discuss this great
inflation myth that I just talked about
I do not want to belittle anybody's
experience with inflation we are all
feeling it uh we are feeling it in our
daily lives it is real but it has been
transformed into something that
Republicans in particular running for
congress are blaming Joe Biden and
democrats for specifically when in fact
there is no economic evidence uh or
mathematical evidence or any other kind
of evidence that that's actually true so
I guess in MSNBC they're celebrating
Halloween early because velshi came as a
park ranger uh it's quite impressive
there are two big Whoppers here and Dan
I want to Joe says the dams are fiscally
responsible
how can that be but then Nancy and you
and we all felt this when she said it
that it's not about inflation it's about
cost of living can someone explain this
to me isn't the cost of living affected
by inflation of course I mean I don't
understand what she was trying to I
understand what she's trying to do she
did not succeed and the weird thing
about the president's speech today he
was giving it two Democratic staffers at
the DNC it wasn't even like you were
going and trying to persuade independent
voters that's a kind of a strange place
to do that let's look back at the
Democratic narrative just this year
first trans inflation was transitory
then it was a rich person problem
remember that little thing from the
White House Podium then it was the
Republicans will make it worse then it
was hey at least Europe is worse than we
are then it's changing the topic they
don't last February in the State of the
Union Address commentary I said that
Biden's accomplishments are now
vulnerabilities and they only
exacerbated that by adding more spending
to the um to the
what do you call that checkbook yeah an
American checkbook and American
Americans feel and they figured it out
but you cannot separate people's lived
experience from the fact that they want
to say well we have a 3.5 unemployment
rate and that should be enough therefore
we should all be happy and we should all
be relieved well people are not relieved
and if 78 of people feel that inflation
is hurting them and 47 said that they've
had to make cutbacks in their regular
purchases because of inflations made
their lives so hard then they're going
to vote on that there's just you can't
you can't change the subject from that
exactly you know I'm going to do my
Harold Ford impression Harold
congratulations on that uh coaching
Victory thank you very much it was a big
win I know that you were excited and a
little nervous and I want to wish you
well having said that you must feel a
bit nervous about what's happening and
doesn't the this young woman to my right
make a great point that your party is
starting to realize that the adult
issues inflation crime and Border are
finally pushing out all that
twitter-based world cult stuff like that
they realize they should have paid
attention to this stuff so the woke
stuff first of all I'm delighted about
this one Saturday but it was soccer yeah
voters are now being presented I think
you're right uh Dana but voters are
being presented a set of choices here
right at the end and I think to the
extent that Republicans are able to
focus I think the biggest weakness for
Democrats
um is that we have not developed a
coherent easy to understand policy on
the border that we've not screened we're
against no cashless bail or we're
against cashless bill
but I got to tell you when it comes to
the economy and inflation I think voters
are have not lost their sense of humor
about where the blame should should be a
sign I think the FED has failed us in a
lot of ways uh their their primary
responsibilities to curb and to fight
inflation they neglected to do that I
think in the way they should have I
think Dana laid out politically there
were some Democrats who uh tagged along
in some of the the way they talked about
transitory and other things we had an
inflation problem a long time ago there
were Democrats Republicans who uh who
who talked about it I read a piece this
week in uh in the New York Times
magazine a congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green who seems to have her own thoughts
and designs on what the majority should
look like if the majority is there and
the kinds of things
no I I differ with her I differ with her
a lot and I do think if you if you
really if you read her I think you
believe that there's going to be a lot
of investigating there's going to be a
lot of exact thing of Retribution and
maybe that's what people want I think
voters see that I don't think all the
parties for that but she said in that
article that she that Kevin McCarthy was
going to have to listen to her to remind
a little bit of some of the AOC talk and
I think that Nance Pelosi has been able
to Tamp that down the questions Ken
McCarthy do that I think another big
issue for Republicans is going to be
Ukraine do we continue to support
zelinski I think there is a there's a
part of the Republican party that said
they don't want to do that and I think
it's going to be incumbent upon Senator
McConnell uh Mr McCarthy to say we will
Tamp that down they've not done that so
I think it's voters taking all of this
this this race is tight I will agree
with you the momentum seems to have
shifted a little bit more to the
Republicans over the last few weeks two
weeks ago we'll see what turnout is and
we'll see see what this final outcome
might be yeah I wonder though I don't
think the war is as big as a pocketbook
but who knows you know judge uh you have
high inflation high crime record border
crossing and it's still close yeah
that's what drives me crazy it's still
how can that be you know it drives me
crazy too I mean but but what drives me
even crazier is when you have a
president who is literally telling the
American people that our economy is
strong as hell and there he is as you
say he's talking to these staffers with
15 days to go why isn't he out in some
of these tougher races you know
campaigning with some of the candidates
and everything that he says is pretty
much a a lie I mean it can be gain saved
by thing I always bring my chart he
keeps saying all the rest of the world
is suffering well they're not suffering
the way we are countries that we
wouldn't consider should be in the same
league as we are they're doing better
than we are with inflation but I think
this whole thing about Nancy Pelosi and
her saying you know well I don't want to
talk about that you know I want to
change the subject that's what the
Democrats have been doing they've been
it's like a shell game they say this is
really what we need to be talking about
that the Republicans they are the
violent ones you saw January 6 they're
the violent ones and forget about the
summer of 2020 forget about the fact
that crime is through the roof and we're
going to talk about it in the next
segment forget about all that just
listen to us and then when you've got
the mainstream media supporting them
with it with their bully Pulpit then
Americans think well gee maybe that
maybe you know it's it's as bad as
bidens as it is but I'll tell you the
last the last interview Biden did where
he's asked about whether or not Jill
Biden supports him I mean this man where
is the 25th amendment I get the you know
you don't want Kamala Harris but this
man doesn't have his wits about him yeah
that was a bit weird what about Ellie is
it velshi saying that the inflation's a
myth Jesse yeah he looked like Glenn
Beck didn't he with gloves was it that
cold this weekend I didn't remember I
thought it was pretty nice so he says
it's a myth and there's no way that this
is the Democrats fault but Morgan
Stanley put out a report that said that
was the American Rescue plan 2 trillion
that supercharged inflation and he's a
business correspondent he didn't know
that and then you had I think it was
Clyburn come out and say yeah yeah we
Juiced the numbers with inflation but
you know we had to do it and he said
that on MSNBC so
the business correspondent on MSNBC
didn't know that but I knew that I'm
neither a business correspondent and I'm
on Fox that's pretty stupid uh I get
nervous when I hear red tsunami you know
my thoughts on Red Wave
you're adding tsunami to this now it's
like it's too good to be true yeah right
now Biden everyone's been saying that
they're gonna have a recession next year
and now Biden conveniently says if you
elect Republicans there's going to be a
recession next year Well Done Joe so
Nancy comes out and they book her and
she just sounds like a political hack
yeah you're asking her what's the plan
on inflation and the and the Speaker of
the House says this is not our plan but
this is how we spin it it's not our
fault because it's happening everywhere
and that we're going to change it to now
it's the cost of living so permission to
make an analogy yes let's say
you have a horrible sex life
and you go to your partner why did I say
yes and you say babe we have a terrible
sex life what are we going to do to make
this sex life better and she tells you
first of all all couples have terrible
sex lives number one and number two it's
not a horrible sex life it's a
challenging sex life did your sex life
improve
Nancy is spinning your sex life it's not
getting any better she's just spinning
it
God perfect tonight
these are her last interviews as Speaker
yes yes you
know uh that was really something
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now